uh josh when you're ready if you want to
go ahead and roll this footage let's
check out some gameplay of ctf on
fragmentation
capture the flag capture enemy flags to
score
[Music]
we attacking or defending
next one
uh
another one
okay so we're gonna let this keep
playing here fernando but uh for folks
that maybe missed the intro this is
sketch joined by a multiplayer designer
senior multiplayer designer fernando
here in the studio
giving you a first look at ctf on
fragmentation one of our new maps that
will be in this preview brandon i'll
turn over to you a little bit um
we saw a chaotic opening there by the
way those two warthogs just head-to-head
right out of the gate but feel free to
kind of point out some stuff and uh you
know just just share a little bit with
us some additional context about what
we're seeing yeah i think first of all
like i would like to talk a little bit
about the map right like fragmentation i
this is one of my favorite maps in in
btv for infinite it has that like
400 steady feels like almost like a
campaign level right and uh i know gives
me that but hella vibes too you know so
it's like i uh as a as a big hello hello
fan it's it's just exciting to play on
it
um
yeah like so big big shout out to uh
cliff shoal that is a level designer of
this uh of this map he he did an amazing
job with it
um
yeah oh yeah that was a skewer right
there
uh but yeah i i think that we're playing
ctf right now um we have done some
tuning especially for uh
for btb in terms of uh
how ctf plays right compared to arena
i will not give a lot of details on that
i hope that people like get to play it
and and and see it in person
but yeah we try to make it uh
just to
embrace really like collaboration and
teamwork uh
so so everyone everyone feels good while
playing like one of my mantras while
working in btv has been like everyone
should feel like a hero in every match
right like you should have like a cool
moment that you feel like oh man i'm i'm
amazing right i'm great at this game and
and hopefully like ctf does that for
uh for people um
this is this is a cool thing i think to
to to mention about the map we have this
thing that we internally call the loot
cave
right where you can bring your uh
bring your ai and hack the the entrance
to the loot cave
and uh yeah you just have to like be
careful there and like escort it while
uh your little guy does its thing
it's just a sub objective right yeah
it's just a sub objective
whoever gets here first gets the loot
essentially yeah exactly right it's just
like an interesting way of bringing more
power into the match and getting cool
toys to play right like i just like
picked up the
uh the gravity hammer there and and
the overshield
so let's let's let's see like find find
some people there uh to use my new toys
with right you got all the toys right
now yeah
oh that guy escaped yeah he got lucky
there and speaking of which too i think
uh by default you guys talked about
scaling the experience a little bit
i believe equipment has like something
like the grapple has more charges in a
big team battle than it would in arena
yeah right yeah for sure like we figured
that given the extra space right like
this square footage of the maps it would
be nice to be able to play with the toys
a little bit more than just like the
the amount of charges that you would
have in arena
and it plays really well right like
especially like if you have the grapple
shot you can just like swing around and
have fun with it for for a bit uh and
and that's that's pretty pretty
incredible
oh you're really going to take this
thing all the way back on field yeah
okay you got a little pick up here yeah
i always like to like um
dry the flag and just like don't have to
walk all the way to the base and
getting a driver which i don't know like
i think this is a good also moment to
talk about how vehicles play in into
into btv right like i think they are
they're there to uh to be used but i
would say that they are very
incorporated into how the mold plays
uh you'll see that the razorback can
interact with the flag for example
and they're just like a core a core part
of btb so
very very big
shout out to to brian berryhill our
vehicle designer uh
that an incredible job to make the
warhawk and the mongols feel the way
it's supposed to feel it it hurts me to
see you lose that hammer after all the
trouble you went to
hack the cave i'm not i'm not sure you
got to kill with it oh my god i got a
good one yeah
oh it's so nice to be back in the man
cannons
this is the commando rifle
just really pretty cool weapon mid-range
right like i always put it in between
the assault rifle and the battle rifle
in terms of like the role it takes when
you're when you're like in a combat
scenario so so i believe some vehicles
will kind of spawn at each base by
default right but then in addition we
have this dynamic element where a
pelican is going to fly in periodically
and drop off vehicles as well yeah
that's a completely new system that we
added for uh
for btb and infinite we have like
pelican drops
bringing vehicles at like key moments of
the match right to like
uh there's like some very smart things
running on the back to make sure that
we don't affect the balance of of the of
the match uh
again big shout out to patrick graham
and
he's an awesome designer that make it
happen both both that and the loot cave
too right so
uh he has been
he has been creating cool cool stuff to
make btb really shine and and make it
make it bigger and better than what it
was
now we also have this dynamic element of
these ordinance drops as well i don't
know if we've seen one yet in this film
right but periodically just cool weapons
are going to rain down from the sky
right
yeah yeah so you you can be just like
wandering around in the map and out of
nowhere like
uh
an ordinance drop falls right in front
of you which is one of my favorite
animations in the game right like you
just like walk to it and it explodes and
it shows you like your new toy
uh
and it's it's it's it's a good
encouragement for people to just be
scavenging around and walking in the
space right i think that btb really
shines is that you have like different
pockets of interaction right like maybe
like this corner we are like playing
with the objective
and like trying to defend the flag right
but maybe in a different corner
somebody's having like a super intense
combat or like somebody else is like
trying to uh stealthy uh
hug the the loot cave for example right
so there's a lot of moments and there's
a lot of things going on in a in a bit
even match so it's it's super exciting
no matter where you are
hey was that loot cave does that respawn
at any point during the match or is that
kind of a one and done no it respawns
you have to let it reboot uh it reboots
for a bit and then you can you can go at
it again okay
they know where we are
oh man you really are the flag runner
huh i love i love running the flag man
like
it's just it's such a cool moment when
you like you know you cap it and it
explodes and you know like you are
contributing meaningfully to
like the outcome of the match it's just
so cool you know
and like i don't know ideally like
like it's a it's a team team team-based
game right so even if you don't bring it
like you just bring it to the 50-yard
line and then it's like it's up to
somebody else you know and and keep like
moving it like little ants in the match
that's that's the thread sensor right
there like just
putting putting in one there just in
case somebody wants to get close to the
loot cave right you can turn back
this gives us an edge
i usually like to use it like that right
like behind a wall and maybe like i can
see somebody like
crouching behind or something before i
commit to a route
really close match
there's something else i was gonna we
could mention real quick too i know
we're watching ctf but um
in the preview we're gonna have uh btb
slayer b2b ctf and also uh a new game
mode called total control yeah
yeah for sure oh here here's the pelican
drop look at that so cool
gets me every time
uh yeah so in terms of modes we we
really try to have like a variety of
experiences in the
in the btb
part of multiplayer
uh like from like very classic btb
uh
slayer experience right it's like how
you remember it you know just like
kill the enemy team right through like
an in-between an improvement on
something like ctf like i was mentioning
right
to like something completely new like
total control
total control is a area control mode
where you have to capture three
different zones at the same time to
score
once you score once once you score one
point uh a new set of songs is selected
uh in different parts of the map to add
some variety
and the first thing that does that three
times wins the match it's it's super
it's become one of my favorites it's
it's it's just so hectic because it just
forces everyone into sort of those three
there's just a lot of intense combat
because everyone's kind of switched
together trying to get those zones
big fan of total control
oh here we go oh oh man so close huh oh
but it looks like there it is it's a win
you and your team prevailed i'm sure
that your uh your multiplayer colleagues
did not go easy on you for the sake yeah
everybody everybody sometimes like plays
a little bit a little bit good
but that was uh your first look at
capture the flag on
fragmentation like we said that will be
part of our multiplayer preview uh
currently with our original plans that
would be coming in the second weekend so
we
most likely will have a double header
approach first weekend's going to be
more focused on arena second weekend
we'll be uh introducing btb so stay
tuned you will get a chance to play that
i promise um now fernando before we wrap
this up um
anything else you'd like to say or sort
of final final words or closing comments
you want to share with the community
today
yeah of course uh i think that
i just want people to know that the mp
team really cares about halo right and
we are all big big fans like franchise
so we really try our best to make this
halo game the best ever we put our
hearts into it so we really hope that
people uh are going to enjoy it in this
flight and whenever uh
we
we launched the full game
uh and yeah i hope you enjoy btp and
share share your clips with us you know
like of all these amazing moments
happening on
on screen